hoy está totalmente dedicada a la
investigación científica pero en el
momento de su creación la estación
espacial internacional también fue un
instrumento político la idea surgió en
1984 y al principio de los 90 el
proyecto estaba en punto muerto todo
cambió en diciembre de 1991 la unión
soviética colapsó y abandonó su programa
espacial muchos ingenieros especialistas
en misiles quedaron desempleados y había
un cierto miedo por parte de rusia de
que se filtrarán sus habilidades sobre
todo teniendo en cuenta que en ese
momento estaba en una situación
económica muy difícil fue una fase un
poco complicada no se es el objetivo era
recuperar a personal ganar habilidades
sí seguro gracias al talento ruso el
proyecto de la estación espacial
internacional resucitó en 1993 se firmó
un acuerdo de cooperación que la
convirtió en el escenario de unión de
los viejos enemigos el ensamblaje de
esta gigante maquinaria empezó el 20 de
noviembre de 1998 a 400 kilómetros de
altura se amarraron 15 módulos con una
capacidad de 900 metros cúbicos 400 de
ellos inhabitables junto con 2.500
metros cuadrados de paneles solares un
laboratorio de más de 400 toneladas
un campo de fútbol que se convirtió en
el mayor objeto artificial en órbita la
estación vuela 27 mil 600 kilómetros
ahora por encima de nuestras cabezas una
velocidad que evita que caiga sobre la
tierra y que permita a los astronautas
desafiar la gravedad cada agencia posee
una parte de la estación en función de
su aporte en el marco de un estricto
sistema de intercambio y escuchamos
copropietarios así que hay que saber
compartir los gastos de la estación
hacemos lo que llamamos partners es
decir efectivamente trueques
desarrollamos material o capacidades de
abastecimiento y pagamos así de algún
modo nuestro alquiler por esta vía
subiera así durante varios años europa
ha pagado su alquiler el desarrollo de
un vehículo para afectar cargas y la
financiación de la cúpula de observación
cupola permitió obtener transportes
gratuitos de la nasa hace más de 20 años
que la estación está ocupada de forma
permanente y así está previsto que
continúe al menos por una década su
utilización acaba de ser prolongada
hasta 2030